yeah we're seeing him uh
a little bit better than we did up in
boston that's it well right field
santander racing back racing back and
makes the catch
good running catch from anthony
santander one down
nice hitting by hernandez but even
better defense by santander who is one
of the goal of glove
finalists so on your toes gets a good
jump
and takes extra base hits away
stewart on it first
that's it hard snagged by debbers
got him
rafael devers who is putting on a
display gets a double play
here as he was able to grab
that airborne and then fire on to first
base for the twin killing
oh beautiful thing full extension there
get it over across the diamond how
stuart got doubled up is beyond me you
cannot get doubled up
you cannot the play is right in front of
you and he doubles him up
nice snag here all the way across they
do double them up
bang bang play at first
news verdugo hit by pitch in the first
with jd martinez on deck
high fly ball twisting deep into left
stewart on the run
forget it it's gone that's a three run
homer
for alex for dugo boy that's some
payback
after lopez drilled him on the calf and
he crunches that one
his first home run of the season that
ball just jumped off his bat
opposite field pop three run johnson
how about that number one on the year
for for dugo and he stung it
red sox on top three nothing
[Applause]
drive down the right field line that one
hit for the corner and that ball's out
of here
and the red sox go back to back as
jd stays red hot and the red sox lead at
four to nothing his third home run
that is vintage jd martinez opposite
johnson's here
how about this this gets out of here
quick and in a hurry
easy opposite way back to back opposites
the bases became loaded with one down
now two away
that one is off the catcher's mitt but
it hangs around the plate
and got him at home plate he's out
we'll see if galves is okay yeah
pathetic got to the plate
way in advance luckily that's why he's
out ball didn't get away that far
you know it's a mix-up is what it was
and it didn't get away that far he is
there and he's blocking it and he's out
slams down the tag i don't know if he
got in underneath or not
the play is called and out great play by
pavetta to be there
yeah they're going to take a look at
this play it's now under review
he's called out who did he get
he could be in does the foot get in
before the tag
i mean is that convincing enough
and he's out yes that is out number
three what an escape by pavetta
oh yeah he got a little help but it's
four nothing boston
here's franco
line drive base hit center field bobcast
will get in the green light he's around
third
here comes the throw not in time and the
orioles are on the board
an rbi for michael franco
number six
got a peck away right here fastball i
mean it's lashed
i don't miss many fastballs
madcastle gets a good read i mean he
didn't even hesitate down four runs you
don't want to get doubled up
but he knew the ball was going to clear
bogart so he scores easily
hot shot up the middle of base hit so
tell you what [ __ ] hernandez has found
his swing
he has two more hits in this one he had
two last night
sox looking for more here in the middle
innings in baltimore
that's a base hit that'll dunk down into
right center hernandez taking off for
third
and he is easily in on what is the
second hit today for alex verdugo
scorching a ball to left center and he
just reaches out and touches
it flips it in right center field he'll
take it first and third
nobody out so first and third nobody out
that's stung in a base set and another
rbi
for jd martinez was 14 of them already
i mean he's not going to miss that i
mean it's fastball right there he stings
it i don't know how many times he's
gotten first pitch fastball
this year and he's been all over it it's
about time
hyde coming out i've talked to a number
of lefty hitters in particular
who i mean everybody loves to hit this
ballpark but left-handed hitters who can
hit it out
really love it here oh there's a high
fly ball into right center field and
that was pretty much on cue that ball is
gone
another home run for rafael devers
[Applause]
was that a high split finger i think it
might have been something off speed he
hit a chain jump out last night
i think that's what it was a hanging
splitter boy he has come alive
three home runs now for raphael
and that's inside and hits him and
that'll force in a run
that's not good hernandez hit by the
pitch they'll make it nine to one
[Applause]
you get jd martinez swinging a bat like
this and now rafael devers was home in
three straight games
and it won't be the last of the nine run
games for the red sox
fly ball well hit right field deep
santondar and there's another one
into the stands for jd martinez
his second home run today and his fourth
of the season i mean this is getting
ridiculous and a nice little pass at the
ball the other way he's ah
nice contact ball gets out of here
i mean this ballpark can't hold this guy
i tell you
fourth home run on the season extra base
hits galore how about this
stuart at first mckenna at third
and that's hit hard deep left field and
it is gone
a laser out of here
i think he's got some pretty good swings
going against pavetta
there's home run number one as an oriole
for michael franco
yeah he uh i mean he hit a line drive
into a double play the first time single
the next time and then hits a hanging
slider right out of here
[Applause]
and mancini has walked reached on an air
and flight out to right field of course
excellent power here
mancini right field hit well way back
and gone right in the corner
just to the left of the ut sign three
run shot for trey mancini
and suddenly things are interesting
right down the middle inside out stay
inside
talk about your front shoulder front hip
happy fan
another terrific day out of jd martinez
three for four
pair of home runs he's driven in three
another drive out to center back it goes
that's a home run jd martinez
with his third home run today
oh man there is hot and then there is jd
martinez right now
[Applause]
unbelievable this is special it really
is every time he makes contact the ball
is gone
i mean he's made so many good pass that
he's touching everything off
three home run game wow
and brings up rafael devers who is
homered in three consecutive games
high fly ball that one to right center
watch this baby go into the seats
that's a two-run shot second home run
today for rafael devers
13-7 this is something i'll tell you
another breaking ball that he loses for
his back leg
four balls in this series four home runs
no cheapies in
any of them
[Applause]
that'll get him run in nice throw from
arroyo to get mancini one down but give
tree mancini his fourth rbi of the game
did it hit him no no gets away from
vasquez and mckenna scores
so it's ball four
let's throw it down to first and the
orioles get their ninth run
throw them a changeover let's get out of
here there you go
hey throw the change up and we're
getting out of here red sox
with a six-game winning streak they
sweep the orioles
that sweet first team to begin a season
with a three-game losing streak or
greater followed by six consecutive wins
since the mets
in 2005.